moscou une ville où il fait bon vivre en
croire onu-habitat le programme des
nations unies promouvant le
développement urbain durable la capitale
russe est même la meilleure mégapole au
monde en qualité de vie et en
développement des infrastructures une
bonne note dans se félicite les
autorités
la reconnaissance de notre ville en tant
que leader mondial en qualité de vie et
développement des infrastructures est
une juste évaluation des énormes
changements positifs qui se produisent à
moscou lundi so n uds habitat ne donne à
moscou aucun avantage formelle mais il
aide à briser les stéréotypes et prouve
que nous sommes sur la bonne voie pour
mesurer la prospérité des mégapoles les
experts d'onu habitat ont pris en compte
des critères tels que l'égalité et
l'inclusion sociale
la productivité la stabilité
environnementale ainsi que la
gouvernance et la législation urbaine le
célèbre parc gorki devant lequel nous ne
trouvons en ce moment est un bel exemple
de la transformation qu'a connu moscou
ces dernières années tombée en désuétude
dans les années 90 2000 c'est
aujourd'hui un des lieux de détente
favori des moscovites chaque année de
nouveaux parcs espèces fait-on
apparaissent faisant de moscou une
véritable ville verte les nouvelles
stations de métro poussait le site comme
des champignons pour faciliter la
circulation
tout ici est fait pour les gens pour les
enfants des parcs pittoresque et
d'excellents restaurants beaucoup de
choses ont été rénovés à moscou à la
fois des monuments architecturaux et
culturels nous aimons vraiment vivre ici
nous en tant qu'utilisateur des
transports en commun à la font surface
et souterrain pour être honnête nous
apprécions cela chaque jour car tout est
si commode pratique beau fonctionnel
vous pouvez recharger votre téléphone
vous pouvez vous connecter au wifi donc
à cet égard maintenant bien sûr il y a
eu une énorme percée et nous vivons une
période qui fait époque les
infrastructures de transport ne s'était
jamais développé de cette façon par
alain rimes
[Musique]
pauvres
quant à la qualité de vie et bien
probablement en général tout s'améliore
à bien des égards mais les gens ont
toujours problème des bas salaires c'est
très difficile pour les autres était de
vivre les pensions de retraite sont
assez basses sinon il y à beaucoup
d'expositions
il ya des théâtres et en général le
programme longévité de moscou me plaît
beaucoup les retraités ont la
possibilité de s'engager dans divers
activités et ne pas rester à la maison
moi en tant que personne qui a vécu dans
de nombreux pays dans le monde je pense
que oui c'est vraiment très facile de
vivre à moscou en termes
d'infrastructures et de possibilités
pour se rendre d'un point a à un point b
en même temps comme dans toute grande
ville il y a des lacunes par exemple
dans les zones résidentielles cela peut
être compliqué quant aux travaux de
déneigement
mais encore une fois je crois que cet
inconvénient ne peut l'emporter sur les
avantages qu'offre la ville actuellement
c'est l'accessibilité des transports des
commerces des crèches des écoles à
proximité
donc en général je suis d'accord avec
l'évaluation donnée par l'onu il y as
certainement me semble-t-il des villes
dans le monde qui sont encore plus
pratique mais je pense que cela tient
plutôt au fait qu'elles sont plus
petites alors que cette grande ville
qu'est moscou s'est amélioré durant ces
dernières années à mon avis
comme n'importe quelle ville moscou et
bien sûr ses qualités et ses défauts une
chose est sûre la capitale russe n'a pas
fini de changer et le récent classement
de nos habitats pourrait bien lui ouvrir
les portes de l'expo universelle de 2030
pour laquelle elle a posé sa candidature
du fils